the universe isn't flat then would that
cause you which is still an open
possibility no pun intended would that
then cause you to doubt both the
inflationary Paradigm and then per force
the Multiverse kind of consequence
within inflation for example yeah we had
if the universe had turned out to have a
like a measurable positive curvature if
we lived in a closed Universe I think
that that would be a very difficult to
accommodate within inflation you could
probably come up with some highly
contrived model to do it but it would be
lots and lots of Gears bells and
whistles in order to accomplish it it
would be unattractive
[Music]